welcome to gamespot gameplay where we
bring you the top games of the day
so that you can make up your own mind
quick note before we get started
this footage is a mix of our own capture
and b-roll provided by devs
the latest addition to rainbow six siege
is blood orchid seeing operators around
the world converging on a theme park
because reasons the map has a few
comical touches like this zombie hand
wall
and generally feels well built as a
medium-sized multi-story building
with some memorable areas i'm looking at
you train lobby the three new operators
don't feel like game changers but do
focus on enhancing team's rushing or
trapping capabilities
ying is an aggressive attacker with her
new throwable that launches a series of
three sequential stun charges
in a nifty little touch this can also be
attached and fire through a wall
results may vary as defenders are often
skilled enough to accurately fire while
under its influence
defenders get ella with their grismond
mine that sticks to surfaces and blinds
attackers
down to 10 seconds
then there's lesion also a defender who
has the more fun trap that when
triggered
shoot spines into your legs that slow
movement and do damage over time
and yes you can pull these spines out of
your shins just do it at the right time
up four last operator standing
new weapons being added to the game are
ella's scorpion evo smg
love that gun and fo12 cliff bed shotgun
ying has a high capacity t95 lsw
and 612 shotgun which has a cool
revolver style rotating cylinder
legion gets the t5 smg and 612 sd
same cool shotgun as yin but internally
suppressed
we still love covering siege and it's a
game that's going strong
so give us the old thumbs up and
consider subscribing to our channel for
more
what operator are you dying to have in
rainbow six siege we're still holding
out for ladder guide
alright let's see the new operators in
action
[Music]
so
uh
[Music]
this time
oh
standing
[Applause]
way more deployed
op4 eliminated
so
ah four eliminated mission successful
[Music]
sensor deployed
impacts
successful
you